used by the international community to
keep american troops in afghanistan
beyond august 31st biden cited a growing
terror terrorist threat as the reason
for holding to the deadline there are
fears that thousands of people who are
eligible to leave afghanistan will not
get out before the end of august many
people are waiting outside kabul airport
to join those who've been airlifted out
to countries around the world including
here to germany
these families have made it out
here at an army base in germany they are
some of the tens of thousands of people
evacuated by international forces from
kabul airport in the last few days
the
the evacuations are being carried out in
a broad cooperation of course and i want
to stress this the us is leading them
without the u.s other nations couldn't
continue the evacuations we need to
recognize that
the august 31st withdrawal set by u.s
president joe biden is seen as a hard
deadline by the taliban
they have warned there will be
consequences for any extension
biden said the u.s was on track to meet
the deadline but is facing mounting
criticism over the chaotic evacuation
each day of operations brings added risk
to our troops
but
the completion by august 31st depends
upon the taliban continuing to cooperate
and allow access to the airport for
those who were trans were transporting
out and no disruptions to our operations
in addition
i've asked the pentagon and the state
department for contingency plans to
adjust the timetable should that become
necessary
as foreign powers scramble to get their
citizens and local helpers out
the taliban appear to be worried about
the brain drain of educated and
well-qualified afghans from the country
while leaving afghanistan the u.s still
wants to inflict damage and loss on this
nation
every day they encourage people by
telling them they will transfer them to
the u.s and other countries and have
readied their planes
as the troop withdrawal deadline looms
hope is beginning to fade for the
thousands still trying to leave
afghanistan
well for the latest from kabul we're
joined now by journalist ali latifi on
the line hi ali and what's the latest
you can tell us about the situation at
kabul airport
um the situation at the kabul airport is
still
a mess there's still thousands of people
sitting in squalor hoping to somehow get
on a flight
sources are telling us that at this
point they're only taking people with
foreign passports and us green cards and
even people who have gotten visas will
not be
allowed on and we'll have to wait
for commercial flights so
it's essentially just been a disaster
through and through
all right now the us and germany say
there's a growing risk of attacks by a
group called isis k now could you tell
us more about them and their
relationship to the taliban
uh they're a group claiming allegiance
to the so-called islamic state but they
have no real direct ties
to the forces that were in syria and
iraq
um the two groups the taliban and daesh
are
long-time enemies they fight each other
in their territory to try and kick one
another out
um so
this is a major problem and this is
something that people fear that now that
the taliban threat has calmed down
that you know the so-called islamic
state forces
will ramp up their efforts but even when
there were first reports of
the so-called daesh forces in
afghanistan uh the former government and
even the taliban said that if one day
they joined together they would fight
against them together
all right now the taliban say life in
kabul is returning to normal but they've
also told women to stay at home for
security reasons what's the situation
actually like in the city over a week
after the taliban's return ali
right now i'm outside one of the biggest
banks in the city
there are hundreds of people in line
desperate to take out their money
after
close to 10 days that the banks have
been closed
um and there's a limit of
30 000 of honeys that people can take
out at a time
uh and so
it's it's a major major problem for
people because
not only are they finally getting access
to some money but they're only allowed
to pick out a small amount at a time and
this
there are people here have been waiting
six hours in line to try and take out
some money
and then the other fear is that because
so many of them are government or former
security forces they fear that after
this this will be their final
uh
basically salary and they wonder what
they'll do in the
future right we're going to leave it
there ali latifi in kabul thank you for
your reporting
well earlier i spoke to analyst tyson
barker from the german council on
foreign relations and asked him if nato
countries will be more wary of backing
washington in the future
one of the
key tenets of nato and allied operations
in the past 20 years and and beyond has
been in together out together and
clearly
that principle is really under question
and under strain in this operation we
see
the the desire of other nato allies
because of the capacity questions to
spend more time protecting the kabul
airport in order to get their citizens
and their allies afghan allies out and
that is something that the us is simply
not willing to do given the condition
set by the taliban